till kickoff the quick rundown war zone
kings one-minute time control war zone
rated seventy-eight players currently
1777 average rating time handicap
30-minute tournament no experience level
required kickoff right here
oh they beat me to it get that thing
over there okay oh okay
oh they beat me to that double fee and
Ketel got me so what do you do you sneak
your knight here you play here and hope
for the best inside castle this isn't
gonna be a quick win or is it uh-oh
seat seats see I'm c2 c2 c2 bishop could
go here it's dead I'm gonna take it
actually I have to just be a little bit
cautious my darks creds but my knight is
there to watch over it and a pile up on
this guy always dead no can't allow that
let's go on too many miss mounts most
clicks here pawn push pawn push bishop
trapped okay let's get rid of the knight
I want my knight right here let's get
rid of that right here hit the bishop
play here actually do this or not
Knight right here get rid of the Queen
get rid of the Queen the Queen has to
run away oh it's a little bit scary
where is it
okay I have to react to that and then
get over here what's the clock situation
let me get rid of that actually I'm
gonna do this just like you get this
square pawn push let's block this off
pawn push why can't this be easy
Queen trade okay it is easy or easier
okay what are my rooks doing okay I have
this give a check Oh everything is hit
get this and then resignation okay back
to tournament no okay no I could have
done that that was just a friend thing I
thought I was clicking on the resign
button I've done that before but I
the game at that point and you know II
for okay Knight c3 Bishop d3 be prepared
it could happen at any moment it could
happen at any moment
fishing poles going fishing fishing
fishing oh it was snuffed out okay my
Brooke is gonna go up and over
first up and then over here we go Brooke
up and then over a Rover they call it
with the rover Bishop takes H I'm gonna
do it Oh in-betweener discover check o
night right here might save the day or
does it know the queen is lost if that
happens meetin two or something o night
right there is actually pretty
interesting
oh is this matin - it's unavoidable no
the night could take the night can
actually take a Knight takes pawn all
they missed it
queen h7 is made back to tournament six
a bunch of sixes
okay Mac Big Mac okay this guy's not
gonna fall for the fishing pole or woody
he wants to drop I don't want to dry I
want to win I don't want to lose all
right let's try this
no no no no I'm gonna do this I think
this is an interesting setup I saw it on
a blitz game to top GM's pretty
interesting the night sneaking away like
this and then and then what castle I
have a good grip over what oh okay I
have it I have a ginormous Center
ginormous Center how can I put it to use
can I put it to use I'm gonna try it
right now pawn push pawn push pawn push
tempos tempos everywhere tempos
everywhere the bishop is cooked at the
end of it
de sac I'm gonna throw this in in
between it in between her resignation
they don't have any time back to
tournament oof
I'm gonna take that one twelve eight six
all right Thunder bomb who's this
Thunder bomb okay oh why do i I need to
wait a bit more I want to go to the
fantasy variation of the Cairo I should
have I guess it transposes but all right
tamer waters here I'm gonna look to get
my Jeep on rolling quickly Queens gonna
have to go back Jeep on push just take
it take that pawnees free okay maybe I
should have done that okay could I get
that I get that pun okay and now this
unless the Queen blocks the Queen didn't
block I'm not getting in a fork though
or is it trapped let's do this right
here next flight square mmm let me get
this in can I get that in Oh
that nights gonna go to a good spot he's
gonna go to a good spot night right here
soon one really really soon maybe kick
that night away okay where's it going
now get this bishop back here night here
next right now I'm on the rook here
opening it up and then and then what oh
I'm on the rook I'm on the rook again on
the other oak resignation Queen to e4
Knight back to e5 on the other rook
rooks are falling everywhere back to
tournament 26:12 okay 22 22 are now 24
24 minutes left lots of time okay
getting ready too many mouths miss
clicks here missed mouse clicks oh oh oh
they're going into a think tank Queen
right here
get out of there night uh-oh trouble
trouble trouble for me
darn it okay I guess I don't have that
anymore
okay let's try um can I be sneaky
somehow no not really I just want to get
that Bishop out of there can I make that
happen oh oh I'm dropping okay no not
dark squares whoa look at the dark
squares right here okay over here and
then okay I'm gonna go here pawn push
and then pawn push again right here I
want to get on these dark squares right
here f4 or not I couldn't maybe take
that pawn maybe a five Queen trade we're
having a queen trade and at the end of
it I stand better I grab this pond next
I'm on the rook and I want to play here
okay and I could get this pawn Navy King
up King up and then f6 let me do this
first I'm gonna take that night as soon
as it goes their opposite color Bishop
ending maybe I'm gonna force the
situation on that night real soon right
now make a decision the rook might end
up being trapped ok the Knights dead
what's happening here this is one of
these rooks are dead I'm gonna be up at
rook at the end of this King up just
have to defend a little bit ok this rook
is going down real soon you'd have to
take one of my bishops take your pick
neither none of the above it was a no
none of the above
pawn push on push pawn push again
they're down on time back to tournament
30 25 20 22 minutes left a lot of time
what are we gonna have here okay ah my
opponent disconnected 1 minute 5
okay so I'll get a W apparently from
this it is saying they're disconnected
you can't see it on the stream but it is
saying that much they are disconnected
and in the meantime let me just do a
primo just in case they come back
and let's see what's going on elsewhere
Oh somebody has they caught up right
here this guy has 30 let's check out his
game what's his name om look for om
where is om refresh om let's go black or
I mean let's go white what's the scoop
here there's 25 seconds before Oh killer
fork got to take with the pond I guess
black is looking like they're going to
win fork that one's dead okay I got to
go back to my game ten seconds left
before this one let's go let's go let's
go let's go don't check the server
whatever you do okay good back to
tournament leaders leaders leaders where
we have 36 32 30s Wow
very very tight just barely a barely up
there a four point edge I could get
paired up with one of those top guys at
any moment it could be a critical game
let's try it again here we go Queen c7
watch out for those Knight moves that's
why I keep doing a6 here it is
how will the knight be challenged h3
doesn't really chase it away uh-oh is
the knight gonna be taken no let's hang
on to him he's needed oh there might be
pawn push here ah there is okay let's
try this fishing okay I can do this with
check woo I got something here got some
material got the rookie and now I have
to watch out for my dark squares I'd
like a queen trade I guess at this point
it's not gonna be a quick win but
oh she's close to dead what am i doing
I better get castle before it's too late
Wow
let's try this and then what here okay
so I'll be gaining a temple Bishop there
wow I'm close to be trapped
okay fortunately I have this clean back
to f3 is needed has to be played
otherwise there's a brutal capture on
this square and stuff let's do this and
then get this rook doing something
bishop here double up double up my
bishop might be challenged at any moment
there's not gonna be a sacrifice there
is there okay I'm on the pond
grab those A&B puns watch out for me
don't let this bishop get here it's
ready to get there what no way
okay I got a run no no no no no no are
you kidding me okay I got to do this
this is scary how much time oh I should
have just been doing time burners time
burners I gotta kill these okay back to
chairman 50 why was I trying to win that
I should have been burning time 51 that
guy has nine games in tea-masters up
there fifty-one fifty forty six forty
two is a bunch of 42 Zandi french efore
quick resign or is it I always ask that
question tonight sometimes it gets
answered d3 Queen e1 Queen h4 we've been
here before
f5 ah my Knights dead look up and over
abandon my sea pond no let's do this
okay pins coming up on the f6 Knight Age
file or F file or G file are available
pin now let's do this the bishop block
is probably good we don't have a bunch
of trades I think that's needed actually
otherwise there's trouble yes that's a
very good move very good but now I win
material at the end of it there is no
pond takes its pinned I'm on the night
I'm on f7 twice now okay so I'm gaining
material here okay and now there's rook
check there's still a pin I'm not gonna
do just yet I'm looking for mates I want
to get a rook lift rook lift let's try
this and what next let's give a check
and this rook actually oh what's this I
got this oh my rook is my rook is uh
okay I gotta go with this I have it
fifteen seconds though I take my bishop
for my knight okay that pre moves
shouldn't a g4 or Knight to f6 they
don't have any time but this game took
forever no time no time no time no time
I actually could be dropping my rook
okay they're down on time back determine
sixty-six I'm pulling ahead no I'm now
67 66 60 double those points right more
open Sicilian oh man c3 why'd you have
to throw c3 in there
it froze me off now push the night away
grab a pond get out of the hole
dangerous zone there goes this there
goes this what does that mean I thought
there could be capture I guess I can't
get the F file but there's gonna be
pressure on this guy I gotta get rid of
that Knight boy
oh boy trouble okay I got this right
I've gotta get rid of that night it's
too good I get that fish up let's get
castle first here it might be a night
check now I have it covered
oh man can I be sneaky sneaky sneaky I
get the piece back
I gotta get developed what's my night
doing how much time 26 I don't have a
lot of time I want to hit the rook oh
man
okay I gotta go for Queen trade Queen
trade please just trade Queens hopefully
this works
just working oh I should have taken the
night which time oh no no no no don't
drop that pod just yet over here get
this guy looking for pigs pigs pigs pigs
pigs
I need pre moves like crazy why did I do
that move that was stupid
look at my rug look at a pathetic rope
right here look at him take a close look
at him he's stupid a four ah eleven
seconds can I get this oh man Chuck I
just got a pre move now just take the
pawn would you checks more checks
I can't move fast eight seconds
okay huh what did I just do
oh man a mouse slipper can I get this oh
you're gonna give you checks checks to
me no don't get me back ranked mate no
back rank mates oh oh oh oh oh oh what'd
I do what'd I do what'd I do what'd I do
did every man woman all men point for
seconds oh I was David Blaine in it
right there again
oh my breath was held right there for
the last seven minutes it felt oh man
that was that was a win objectively
wasn't it yeah my king versus two rugs
he's a champ
he was a champ right there give a check
if the knight blocks Queen check on c6
uh-oh King has to move Oh
click resignation or my traps no not
just take the rook just take the rock
what you token why was I not gonna take
the rook scene goes back to tournament
104 yes 12 minutes and change nuba yes a
quick resigner oh I'm getting thrown
points point throwers turbo eg I'm
getting showered with points right now
oh fantasy when am I gonna take an extra
second to think about that the second or
third move right there
okay f7 let's guard this guy 95 you know
let's not do 95 let's get out of the pin
pins are not good if you're in them
let's back up Bishop to e3 okay get this
Knight kill the knight is the plan keep
the pin is also another plan keep my
queen active knight here made me pretty
good let's try this active bishop pair
is the knight close to being trapped him
on the rook I want to come back here
okay this bishop needs to go they should
really try to get rid of that let's do
this otherwise there could be that
wonderful commentary right there let's
play this otherwise there could be that
let's play this because otherwise it
could be that oh yeah I was thinking the
same thing which one do I want this guy
good enough what is my knight doing on
g3 what a stupid piece let's go oh the
rook is sitting sad over there sitting
sad don't drop her up this time whatever
you do don't you dare drop the rock okay
pac-man pac-man pawn push them he's
passed don't drop your rook don't you
dare
uh-huh check come over here Oh forks
forks forks
I got a fork no no no no design time we
got yes back to tournament 134 123 105
okay these guys are right there right
there they are
okay let's go let's go Queen c7 c7 is
gonna get pushed away and now the Queen
is gonna get kicked away 86 oh the queen
is dead resigned time I like saying that
resigned time Oh check bishop block if
bishop blocks if it should block bishop
before okay I have these squares covered
I should've just taken that pawn maybe
let's try this okay dark squares get
that night out of here
and look for me I'm gonna push the pod
look for me what's happening pawn push
is gonna be missed it might be missed
take the pawn however mate they back to
tournament
154 123 110 nine minutes and change mark
mark at Oh hmm let's try it an open
Sicilian you can still get violent
without a doubt
very very violent so let's try this F
for fish up out here queenside castle
Queen f3 g for g5 I'm gonna take this G
for g5 now
flu this works okay let's go pawns let's
go
f5 next it's a little scary being on
that dog and I want to queenside castle
soon I think what squares do I want a
week in the dark squares light squares
let's get castled first and then think
about stuff okay I'm on the night I'm on
h7 mmm-hmm okay let me do this Oh b2 b2
I just want to open this up I'm on the
night take this oh man oh man please
don't let there be something good please
hold up shelter let this shelter be good
right here oh it's not being good okay I
got to take that night out of there over
here my dark squares are so bad they're
just bad look at this what am i doing my
queen is guarding it sneaking in being
sneaky time oh I couldn't take the
bishop take the [ __ ] up it's a free
piece take the free pieces if they're
there
wow that was a free piece right there in
d4 was staring right at me was saying
come get me and I didn't get him ah okay
Knight f6 open this up finally check
grab here no matter what got the Queen
at the Queen mate next actually just
anything you want to burn their time
time burners I'm looking for time
burners no time back to tournament 174
163 man I got to keep went in here
seven minutes still a lot of time it's
like three four more games each pawns
what's the bishop gonna do being sneaky
they were too pre move mode
they were pre moving they were a pre
mover I did a fake right there I juked I
jerked the bishop right there it was
officially Jude watch where you going
night uh-oh he's dead he's a dead man
the Queen's hit tricky Queen oh hey
let's go my knight right here put him
over I should take that pawn okay
looking for this making two one two
three two three the King is running for
the hills
quit running no let's not do that
where's the mate oh right here right
here was made just move anywhere okay
back to chair that is pretty quick 194
163 15 games in there 14 163 I could get
paired up with that second guy at any
moment that'll okay fantasy this could
lead into fishing pole like positions be
five I think is a good move oh I just
dropped upon oh they're gonna take it no
they're not
okay let's defend that bishops a pain
being outside that pond chain difficult
to deal with but I want dropping this
I'm still okay with it kind of so pawn
push coming up the knight can't move if
I get the bishop okay something's
happening here like so I'm gonna throw
an in-betweener okay no no it's coming
back oh I just try my queen oh I dropped
the lady oh it's not taken okay let's
come back Wow my dropping stuff and it's
not being taken what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do the lady was right
there
she was right there at h4 waiting for
the bishop okay
chop-chop again looking for mates move
rook just move there's gonna be Queen
captures it's a good move let me just
come back now so much for that no no no
no no no what's the time mm oh man this
is very scary why did I do that I just
want to give check where's that rook
gonna go I gotta get I have to get out
of this pin time situation we're gonna
have why oh this is bad okay I got to
get out of this pin okay now it's
actually good but what's the time
situation I have less time than them
I just dropped a bish up the brook check
can I miss that get a ticket now Queen
trade I should have gone with the Queen
trade I get that check take attack my
bishop attack my bishop yes
Oh back to term at the Donna time 214
195 four minutes left come on
oh man that was a bad game that was
really bad hung Queens and everything oh
I get the rook first take the knight
take this Knight he's not there it's
like last game go somewhere else bishop
okay now I'm gonna take this this this
and then get developed here my dark
squares are weak you take this Knight
thing let's get my knight back into play
let's take them out before it beats me
up and let's get this in my Knight wants
to go to f4 late on f4 is where I want
to be so let's go there I got him there
by force I know there could be a pawn
push but now there's not here we go
there he goes and there he will stay
strong position if the H file opens up
my king goes to f7 my reps go to this
file
my nights here watching over the pond
attacker and defense can't be chased
away either pressure on this and I'm
gonna do this just to get that H pun why
did I do that I think it should still be
alright if pawn takes I just hide behind
the white pawn I'm on this twice it
can't be defended I got the Queen uh-oh
resignation okay bad news bad news right
around the corner this pawn is a good
defender for me this is me one two
okay back to Turman 234 235 somebody has
a one-point lead let's go two minutes 12
seconds
somebody has to knock that guy off I'm
only gonna get one more in maybe maybe
just one more
ah come on come on come on come on
if that guy wins this game I can't I
can't do it
is he winning his game please say no
come on a draw even if he has a draw f7
Knight here I'm hitting both right here
a lot of pressure on it mates mates
mates mates Queen to h4 get rid of the
knight when I hang on to that guy he's
really good I want to get okay let's do
this
take here take the knight or something
um okay I got to go back rook on H
all right rook to the G file okay grab
on grab on that h6 square oh they're
defending my queen was hit that time I
saw it I saw it that time okay let's
come back h6 is back on let's clear the
way what am i doing what is my knight
doing I need to get this win and I'm not
I definitely have to win this game in
order to win
come on right here she'd take that pond
clean tray and I don't want to Queen tre
please don't do Queen trade okay
age six am i crashing through on this
mates mates meets mates check right here
right here throw in a couple checks a
zigzag checks check check check
everybody loves to check checks and more
checks I got the Queen just go anywhere
how much time how much time how much
time how much time let me get the
Wynwood I got what I got what I got
ah he that's 265 click resigner quickly
quick quick quick quick quick resign you
know you want to resign right here can i
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no oh second please oh man
second place confetti what can you do we
had 21 games in I got 18 17 15 ah good
games all where is that he lose the
first place what is going on